heidi heidi kugelmann bitte ich an arme
aus boston neues eingepackt mensch
maßgebliche kleider schuhe sonnencreme
bücher kann er nicht jeder mit zwei paar
unterhosen und ein paar sorgt nur
auskommen wo ist das problem ja kein
problem dann brauchen wir wegen des
chaos' haben dass unser einziges haus
aufräumen bei ist ja nichts mehr drin
können wir jetzt langsam los verhandelte
vielleicht mit langsam sondern sogar
schnell weist uns kommt mal wieder im
stau 3 selber schuld würden wir mal
fliegen wie die nachbarn nach thailand
zum beispiel dann hätten wir nie nein
stau kommen ja beim fliegen darf es aber
nur einen koffer mitnehmen und außerdem
ist autofrei praktischer zum verreisen
ach ja und warum bitte schön ja wenig
unterwegs biesel monaco nicht nur
flugzeuge schlecht rechts ran fliegen
oder
[Gelächter]
du leider nicht
die heutige
wahnsinn urlaub in urlaub fahren das
kann zwei das kann zwei überlegt die
ganze zeit was machen wir da eigentlich
genau wir fahren in urlaub
das ist ja mein mann und ich streiten
uns nur noch über das urlaubsziel ja
genau weil ich möchte nach italien und
sie will mit
fahren sie wieder an den gardasee zum
campen ina logisch weil vielleicht gibt
es ja am see noch irgendwo ein
quadratmeter immer noch nicht kennen
aber
campingurlaub in italien
das macht doch heute kaum noch jemand
wenn wir waren gerade in thailand und
ich muss wirklich sagen
und alles super preis günstig online
gebucht siehst du hörst du online online
die brauchen nicht online ich rufe im
campingplatz bei der frau rosi an und
sagen wir kommen am 29
fertig
nächstes jahr machen wir eine weltreise
eine weltreise
das wär doch mal was welt 30
ich glaube dass ich das essen an die gut
was ich noch jetzt fast vergessen ich
brauche sie nicht mehr geld thailand
dubai singapur für sie ein italienischer
sprache reiseführer und wasserträger
urlaub hitze und abkühlung der noch eine
express oder springers worden
so wird es nichts wenn sie des tors
hinten eine backen wollen sie müssen mit
den koffern anfangen den schweren nach
unten ich weiß ich selbst
meinen sie außerdem nicht das wissen
spät dran sind heute eigentlich meine
ich überhaupt nicht weil wir fahren
immer gern ein bisschen später weil man
den stau 3,4 dem trottoir die früher
fahren damit sie den stau reinkommen
haye verteidigen china fahren habe
ich hab alles alles so alles auf anhieb
osten hier auch ausgemacht nein aber da
kann es passieren bei den wassern habe
ich auch an gelassen
ich will mich ja nicht eigentlich
norbert fährt ihre tochter heuer gar
nicht mit den urlaub
scheiße wer
weiß es auch nichts besonderes wir
fahren heute nur in den urlaub ab man
man man so viel hast du alles dabei
brauchst du noch irgendwas nein navas
nein nein du brauchst nichts mehr oder
nein ich habe alles dabei keine ahnung
ja hauptsache das handy ist dabei
das ladegerät
jetzt müssten nur noch die zwei taschen
ins auto
wenn sie den koffer dort links mit
unterbringen wird es überhaupt nix oder
ganz recht hast die tasche besser rein
jetzt sehe ich doch bisher dass dort die
tasche rechts überhaupt kein platz war
wie ein see geflogen hätten wir das
problem nicht so nun bin ich jetzt noch
einen einzigen ton höre dann fahren wir
überhaupt nicht in urlaub gut fahren wir
eben nicht in der wohl aber ich habe
sowieso keine lust mehr es war wir
fahren nicht nach italien
so viel du bleibst jetzt da natürlich
fahnder
jetzt müssen nur noch um wie diese zwei
taschen da rein
hat aber
ich will ja nicht umsonst den ganzen tag
tetris
soll die sophia vielleicht auf ihrem
handy navi nachschauen wie wieder
hinkommen entschuldigung aber ich schaue
aus wie bin ja auf der prinzessin der
herzen war ehrliche antwort sie wissen
aber schon dass dieser tunnel gesperrt
ist ja das weiß ich aber nur bis zum 28
zentrum haben ja für den 29 gebucht und
heute ist der
boß das heute ist erst 28
warum bin ich bloß mit zu einem idioten
zu sein ich mein kalender kann er lesen
von sophia okay jetzt
sagen sie mal wo sie ja heute nicht in
den urlaub fahren wir machen heute abend
ein dia abend 12.000 ausgesuchte fotos
aus 16 jahren thailand ich lade sie ganz
herzlich ein wie kommst du bitte wieder
einiges zu besprechen ist
hat zwei wundervolle optionen hoffmann
raus aber ich glaube ich wähle die
dritte möglichkeit die stimme die ganze
nacht ein tunnel
[Applaus]
[Musik]